Last month, when I visited Taiwan for a business trip,...
I went into this shop that sold music CDs,...
...autographed goods, magazines and so on.
Then I found items with "BoA",...
..."Rain" and "Super Junior's" faces on them.
I mean,...
...I did see on TV that Korean popular culture is just sweeping across Asia,...
...but after witnessing this with my own two eyes,...
...I have to admit that Korea rocks.
The trend has really given Korean stars fame...
...and has done much to boost the image and prestige of Korean pop culture.
But do you predict that this trend will last forever?
Or is it just a temporary fad?
What I know so far is that it's been around for a long time,...
...longer than I thought;...
...so it will be around for another 10 years or so.
I was actually surprised to hear that even in North America,...
...Korean movies are showing at regular theaters.
In doing so,...
...Korean contemporary culture does not only pass along Korean culture,...
...but also paves the way for many other Korean businesses abroad.
Recently, I heard that in India,...
...Korean TV dramas and soap operas are a big hit.
The government, I think,...
...should encourage more exporting of Korean pop culture,...
...and promote it on a regular basis.
Certainly, I admit Korean pop culture...
... has great value as a cultural asset in Korea.
Promoting Korean pop culture with various media tools is very important, too.
I hope it can spread all over the world...
...not just in Asia, you know.
I'm also expecting more Korean pop artists to make it in the world!